dane dunning got for his seventh start
he's two-and-oh is era in the low threes
you look at some pretty impressive
numbers for a young pitcher just coming
back from surgery paces remain empty and
here is wilson contreras for this series
on the ground at third three straight
round balls for dane dunning monkatta
does indeed get the out
big john lester pitches for the cubs
tonight
and a ground ball right to the second
baseman kipnis
that's a quick one two three for john
that's one thousand innings as a cup
it's a little sinker away here and you
can get him
cold strike three hayward disagrees
[Applause]
david ross not too happy with angel
chris bryant back in action
thanks for being with us porter and kb
with the first hit of the night here
comes javi and yes he's batting
right-handed
dunning to second one
madrigal the first throw gets away cubs
are gonna get a run bryant scores it's
one to nothing madrigal kind of hurried
his throw and ray you couldn't handle it
so here is james mccann
three and two
[Applause]
mccann hits it skyward right center
field toward the alleyway it goes and
it's gone
tie ball game james mccann goes deep
this game tied at one and james hits his
seventh his 15th ribbon in and luis got
himself a base hit last night and you
wonder if that'll get him on track
rip third base side kicking off of brian
and there is the type of dagger we've
seen
early in the year for luis robert here
is nomara mazara
left side nomar has got a base hit
robert's on his way home the throw will
not come and the sox take the lead now
the cubs have the bases loaded contreras
do up
2-1
big chopper
first base abreu can't find it and it
sits on the infield and the cubs get a
run with no out now they're gonna say
they're gonna call maybe interference
here
they're gonna say dead ball
so watch again abreu
goes up for it and after it leaves
jose's area it clips anthony rizzo
bases loaded two down cubs have not
scored in the inning they had the bases
loaded with nobody out and now it's up
to chris bryant
[Applause]
chris bryant in the ear to left
it is
a grand slam
welcome back kb
five to two
[Music]
you talk about a home run feeling good
carratini his first one of the year
uh last night but this one is so sweet
for chris bryant mccann robert and angle
coming up
james lifts it
to right field
and it drops hayward looked
at jason kipnis and nobody made the play
the sox get a base runner out of nowhere
another three and two coming from
leicester
mazzara takes ball four
bases loaded one out here in the fourth
slow grounder to shortstop baez bare
hands double clutches safe nick beat it
out and indecision attacks the cops he
picks it up with a bare hand and then
looks at home
he might as well just take the easy out
at first they're giving it to you
two out monkatta
three balls and a strike lester two
monkata
inside ball four johan takes a walk and
it's a five four ball game ryan tapera
is now the man on the mound for the cubs
inheriting
a rather unenviable situation bases
loaded two outs and the always dangerous
jose abreu at the plate
[Applause]
to left field schwarber back it is off
the wall a ringing hit from freyja
the carousel starts where will it stop
throw to the plate not in time
jose is on his way to third he is in
there safely
jose abreu pounds one to clear the bases
one out madrigal's still at second
three and two for montgomery
johan
[Applause]
what a way to make a living
first home run since august 17th
johan
gives the socks a 4-run lead as craig
kimbrell comes in that's the budweiser
pitching change and really uh you know
the results tonight and tomorrow
don't matter for the cubs they're locked
in as the nl central champs and the
number three seed and they will host the
wild card round
but you'd rather win than lose
they trail by four late in this one
99 to get them cheese glorious cheese
bread you went on the swing that's two
strikeouts for kimbrell man it's like
two strikeouts per inning every time out
isn't it alex coleman this is a tune-up
for him non-safe situation and had
another great year
to win nothing for them strike three
and on
third base sign monkana snares it and
the sox put it away
9-5 the final score jose abreu one big
swing johann moncada added on
and the offense breaks out the sox in
second place all alone it would take a
win tomorrow and a minnesota loss for
the sox to win the american league
central